men need to respect women period so you  should respect women  i am a woman so [ __ ] you if you don't  think so and how dare you sit up here  and try to say that women aren't worth  respect [ __ ]  am a woman i just became a woman it's  just like are you [ __ ] kidding me  people don't respect me period and i'm  i'm already black so it's just like uh  yeah that already goes against me  anyways but still  [ __ ]  you  piece of living garbage gum on the  bottom of my shoe oh my god i wish i had  a tissue for the blood i would  might suggest it's your behavior not  because you're black or a woman  sorry can i stop here can i stop here  can i stop here please i believe it's a  man  that woman  the country were guilty until proven  innocent